la veuve de la victime
vadim chichi marine évoque ses remords
il est accusé par le tribunal de kiev
d'avoir tué par balle un civil ukrainien
de 62 ans
vous répondez vous du crime que vous
avez commis
oui je plaide coupable je
sais que vous ne serez pas en mesure de
ne pas redonner mais je m'excuse et je
demande pardon pour tout ce que j'ai
fait
l'homme de 21 ans dit avoir suivi des
autres au moment des faits la colonne de
blindés dans laquelle ils se trouvaient
est attaquée avec plusieurs soldats ils
décident de voler une voiture pour ne
pas être capturé et croise alors la
victime qui menace de les dénoncer vadim
chichi marine tir à bout portant
il a reçu une balle dans la tête j'ai
couru vers lui et le crâne était percé
le soldat russe encourt la prison à vie
mais malgré la détresse madame chez
lipova dit ne pas être opposé à un
éventuel échange entre le meurtrier de
son mari et des prisonniers d'ukrainiens
cette audience est une première pour les
crimes de guerre russes perpétrés en
ukraine mais ne sera pas la dernière
plus de onze mille dossiers ont été
transmis au parquet ukrainien et une
quarantaine de suspects ont été arrêtés